Film Courage: three to five common mistakes
you see new actors making on set?
Bill Duke, actor/filmmaker/author: Common
mistakes?
Number One.
No actors (for the most part and some actors
which it’s just that there is ego is out
of shape) believe that acting is about talking
or speaking their lines.
They have no understanding of the art of listening.
We are having a conversation.
What a conversation is, you speak.
I listen closely to what you’re saying because
I want to respond to your question.
Most actors have memorized their line so no
matter how you say it or what’s anything,
they respond with their line.
On camera it looks like now what a minute,
she was crying?
“Oh Becky, want to go to the prom?”
No, no, no…she was crying when you gave
her the flower?
“Oh yeah.
Take two.”
“Hey Becky, want to go to the promo?”
[Laughs]
“Cut!”
We’re going to have a long talk in the corner,
okay?
Second biggest mistake I think is that
some actors are not collaborators.
You know it’s like they’re so insecure,
it’s their scene.
And so they go in with the attitude like “Well,
this is my scene because I have more lines
than you.”
And there’s two people on the scene, there’s
two people on the scene.
You are doing a monologue if it’s just you.
But there are people’s egos that are just
so large that you’re not even there.
So it’s like that’s how good they can
be and that’s annoying as hell.
The third thing is nerves.
I mean I’ve literally seen…I’ve had
to stop shooting a scene because in the middle
of the scene the actor was sweating so badly
that we had to cut.
“Are you okay?”
“What happened?
What happened?”
When I say sweat, I’m talking about [motions
all down the face] because internally they
are so worried about the fact that they are
not doing it right that they just…something
internally happens and they are just terrified.
So as a director you get a call and you give
them…make sure that they know they are protected.
You’ve got to give them assurance because
acting is responding, it’s surrendering.
It’s not holding on to safety.
That’s easy for me to say but try it sometimes.
Try going in and trying to do it and you don’t
know how it’s going to turn out.
You ask
“How is it?
How did it go?”
“It was great.”
“Can I see it?”
You don’t know how it was because you were
involved in it and not knowing what to do
is…we’re not feeling safe that you’ve
done it well.
It’s a challenge.
Film Courage: Well, they say having a big
ego and a small ego is pretty much the same
thing, it’s just sort of different ways
of dealing with it?
Bill Duke: Having a big ego I think is a sign
of small self-regard.
Having a small ego is similar.
I think…I forgot his name but Wayne Dyer
(I love Wayne Dyer)?
He said “The key to having a great life
is to get rid of your ego.”
And the audience said “What are you talking
about?”
He said “Do you know what the word ego stands
for?
E.G.O.”
He goes to the board and says “E. Edging.
G. God.
O. Out.”
He said “Your ego edges God out.
And without that force in your life you have
nothing but empty accomplishments.”
And he says “Try eating those empty accomplishments
when you’re sitting home alone because nobody
likes you in your mansion.”
He said “It’s more comfortable than being
on the street.
But when you ride by that person sitting on
the street, he looks familiar.”
I think he’s brilliant and true.
I know very wealthy people who are miserable.
There are many.
Money didn’t fill the hole.
Cars didn’t fill the hole.
Clothes didn’t fill the hole.
Vacations didn’t fill the hole.
Relationships didn’t fill the hole.
There is something else you have to have.
I’m not saying I know everything.
But I do know because I’ve had a lot of
it, that all those things don’t fill the
hole.
If you don’t have self-love…even if somebody
else loves you, if you don’t have self-love.
I tell my daughter everyday you know, never
forget men treat you the way they see you
treat yourself.
Don’t treat yourself the way you think he
should perceive you.
Treat yourself the way you want to be treated.
I think it’s a general for people, I love
quotes so…I can give you three of my favorite
quotes?
Film Courage: That’s sounds great.